five sparkled face just outside the
range again we've seen this re-run from
the last one there's the rage gets the
jab
okay wonder woman working on sparklefish
16 seconds left on the clock watch it
because it's going to play a huge role
beyblade not good watch oh my god this
is going to be it
is going to take over super kimmer 2014.
he needs to swim a little bit faster or
else caleb is going to take this very
convincingly here oh my god oh my god
no oh my god
[Applause]
you finish with a chip damage are you
serious three
brilliant block super keemer just knows
when to block but not this time catches
him ducking or moving
watch the damage
nice too
last chance here now for kirakira one
more what a block
okay no way there's no way he must come
back surely i burn
oh
god one
big magic forward air just sending it up
nice
adjustment
give some rage oh that's gonna be yes
the reversal from blackazama i first
blew stuff
that was insane what a player
[Music]
[Music]
you